The greatest common factor for
these two numbers is .8, and
the greatest common factor for
these two numbers is 3.5.
Nice thinking if you've
got these two factors.
We know .8 divides into 1.6 two times.
So this simplifies to 2.
And .8 divides into 2.4 three times.
For these two numbers 3.5
divides into itself 1 time.
And 3.5 divides into 7, 2 times.
We've removed a common factor
from the numerator and
the denominator since
they simplify to 1.
This leaves us with 3 times
1 in the numerator and
2 times 2 in the denominator.
So we'll have 3 divided by
4 times 10 to the third.
Three-fourths is 75 hundredths, so
we have 0.75 times 10 to the third.
Moving this decimal place
one spot to the right,
we would decrease by a power of 10.
So this number is the same as
7.5 times 10 to the second.
Notice how this number is
in scientific notation.
Since this number right here
is between one and ten.
The number above it isn't
in scientific notation.
Since the absolute value of this
number is not between one and ten.
So for our final answer,
we know that this division
simplifies to 7.5 times 10
to the second or just 750.
[BLANK_AUDIO]